good morning believe nation today's
message is put in the time over to you
Mark Cuban I'll be cliches and say that
you know there is no failure you just
learn from it but you know you just go
you have you just have to put in the
time I think what I learned most is that
everybody's got will and everybody's got
dreams and everybody's got aspirations
but it's only the people that really put
in the time that get there and and I
think I learned most that despite any
any setbacks that if I just keep on
grinding I keep on working that I
usually can outwork people and and then
you know I also learned that no matter
how many times you fail it really
doesn't matter all it takes is one hit
and then everybody can call you an
overnight success everybody has dreams
right everybody has a life for
themselves you have a life for yourself
that you want to be better than where
you are right now and in order to get
there in order to make that happen you
have to take action because if you are
not taking action put it in the time
you're gonna stay where you are and that
life that you want is just gonna stay a
dream instead about you turning into
reality I believe that be to be a
successful entrepreneur there are three
things that you need to have first you
need to have the dream you need to have
the idea what are you going to actually
do and that's the easy part most people
have a dream for themselves to is you
got to take action you got to start you
got to take some small action right now
to start whether that's leaving your job
whether that's opening the business name
with us making a customer call whatever
it is you have to start and a lot of
people don't have the courage or
gumption to go and take that one little
small step and in the third part is you
got to not quit when times get tough
when it's hard when you're not meeting
the expectations for yourself when
you've already gotten worse than your
worst case scenario you got to keep
going those are the three things that
successful entrepreneurs have in common
they have an idea they have a dream they
start and they don't quit I look at my
business and one of my dreams is to
build up this YouTube channel and as a
result I'm putting in the time right I'm
moving now to a 3
per day scheduled on the channel for
most people that's crazy right that's
insane three videos a day how do you
find time to record those videos to edit
them to put them up where most people
struggle to get one video a week up on
their channel I'm doing three a day I'm
putting in the time because I'm chasing
my dream if you want your dream to
become a reality
you need to put in the time as well
beliefs so my question the day for you
today is how much time are you putting
into your business and where is it being
spent I'm curious to find out leaving
the comments below and I'm gonna join in
the discussion thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events vessel